should get started here um I think we
have two items of business ahead of us
toight one is I'd like to get I receive
some testimony from Michael Nor from
Department of Environmental Services
thank you for coming
today and uh I'm hoping it's an
opportunity to fill in a lot of the
questions that I have as far as uh
moving forward with a uh extended
producer responsibility Bill the other
thing which I would I'm relishing
occurring here is a conversation about
where we would like to see this Bill end
up areas of legislation that we'd like
to maybe try to cover in this areas of
legislation that would maybe recommend
for further study down the line and
areas we don't see as part of the scope
of this uh legislation and if we could
get a sense of that before the uh and
that's getting a sense of it would help
us moving forward over the next couple
of weeks I would hope so without any
further Ado may I call Michael York nor
I'm
sorry and just for the record the
name uh thanks representative partial
and uh honorable members of the
committee good morning uh for for the
record my name is Michael norc uh and I
am here to represent the solid waste
management Bureau at the Department of
Environmental
Services um so I just just wanted to
provide some general comments
um relative to Extended producer
responsibility I want to preface
anything that I say by just noting that
I am not by any means an expert on the
subject of extended producer
responsibility but I am probably the
best suited person at the department to
provide some insight
um one thing that I note is that uh
often these proposals you know policy
initiatives for epr
are uh directed at Dees to administer
and oversee uh and one thing that I just
want to say for the record is that we
are uh always sensitive to these kinds
of policies in terms of how they might
affect our current program structure and
resources
um you know it's obviously an important
topic and something that a lot of other
states are looking at but I just want to
note that Dees is not currently
resourced to administer such a program
um so if if there were to
be uh some policy initiative to come out
of this committee uh I would just uh
advise that it might be helpful to the
department if that policy were to
Envision how the department would be
resourced what tools it would be given
to basically carry out and oversee that
program I was encouraged by testimony
provided by uh Folks at the last
committee meeting where they did
acknowledge that you know there needs to
be proper uh oversight and
administration by the by the state
government uh and that the government
does need to be uh you know given the
tools whether it's Staffing or uh other
funding mechanisms to basically oversee
that
program um you can stop me at any point
too if you have questions I don't really
have a a set u you know list of talking
points or anything but the only other
thing that I wanted to mention was
um as far as I'm aware epr programs can
be structured in a number number of
different ways um some of the older epr
programs would basically give state
government complete oversight of the
program uh I think a lot of newer epr
programs are kind of leaning more
towards
a middle ground where the industry has
some oversight and input into the
process and and the day-to-day
operations um using something like a
producer responsibility organization or
a PR um so that organization is is
basically uh the mechanism by which
industry can have
some oversight and input into the
process the pro usually would be the one
kind of doing the day-to-day operations
of collection and management of whatever
the product is that's covered by the epr
program
um so uh an a clear example of that
would be like paint care which is
something that has been administered and
implemented in a number of other states
in the Northeast um you know it's a a
system whereby used architectural paintt
can be collected for recycling or other
disposal proper disposal and management
um and the paint Care Organization is a
pro so it's basically funded by the
industry and they administer the
oversight and implementation whereas
government still has a role in terms of
you know enforcement and just general
setting guidelines and uh performance
objectives or those kind kinds of things
maybe there's some Ru making that that
needs to be taken into account um but I
just I just note that because um if
government is to be expected to take on
complete oversight of the program that's
obviously going to take more resources
uh versus a pro model which is probably
going to
be a little bit less for the the ongoing
implementation and oversight there's
obviously going to be some startup uh
you know you know the standing up the
program getting it off the ground Ru
making there so there's going to be some
initial uh impact to resources and and
Staffing at the department but on an
ongoing basis a PR model could
potentially provide uh you know a more
efficient model and I think from what I
understand industry also tends to be
more in favor of a PR model because then
they have some input into the process um
so those are the only comments that I
wanted to to make but if if the
committee has any questions for me I'm
I would like to ask you to elaborate a
little more on
uh
PR's and
uh I guess my one of my questions you
much involvement could we expect from
IND I mean mean to my way of thinking
perhaps you know I mean again we're all
green at this
um new territory but I could see
initiative where you have a preo an
industry and the uh State all being all
having a seat at the table but would
that make it unwieldy having that
many that much involvement by these
different concerned um
parties thanks for the question
representative I'm I'm actually I'm not
really sure in terms of the there are
probably others that are more um
familiar with the
the nitty greedy details of how these PR
operate
um the best I can say is that from my
limited knowledge I believe a PR is
really responsible for like the the
day-to-day operations of the program
whereas state government in those models
where there's a pro and then state
government is um kind of providing
General oversight enforcement Authority
if there are problems uh you know
setting targets or uh General guidelines
for performance like what are you know
if if if there's a goal or something to
collect x% or you know manage this
material in some way um the government
kind of sets those those overarching
goals uh and then the pro Works to meet
those goals so I I don't know I don't
know that I can offer a really
definitive answer on that but that's
kind of my limited understanding is that
they're kind of working in tandem um but
but in terms of the operations and
day-to-day aspects uh Pro is really the
one managing like the financial aspects
of it and you know PR are often funded
by industry like manufacturers or
producers will pay into the pr
organization based on their market share
or based on I think you heard about Eco
modulated fees based on the
recyclability or or the difficulty in
management of the product that they
produce so they will pay a higher fee if
it's more difficult to manage versus
other companies that may produce
something that's a little bit easier to
recycle or manage so they'll pay a lower
fee if I could ask about um eom
modulation of the prices do you think it
may be a simpler uh feat to have the
state involved with those aspects of it
uh less subject to uh industry
adjustment
that's not really addressing the problem
I mean I can I can I mean there's
there's so many different areas there I
know we're moving in a green area and
we're doing a lot of speculation here um
but I think it's probably one of my
chief concerns personally
is who is going to be the Watchdog on
all of this I I mean even the fees I
think that we can get around that we can
get around so many other aspects of this
um but but the Watchdog itself that's
that's you know that's I think it's I
think I speak for most of us and saying
that would probably be our chief concern
um and so let me go back again and ask
my you know my very IL defined
question
um
would State
involvement in a
PR counterbalance
industry
um management of the pr in such a way so
that we do get Fair Echo modulation fees
and the
like or is it you think that they do
they effectively run themselves I I
think I understand your
question again very limited knowledge on
how this works there's probably multiple
different ways to structure it um but I
believe in most cases the pro is
governed by rules that a agency a state
agency might set so the agency might
decide what fees
are going to be applied based on
material types or based on product types
or whatever so it's not like the pr is
always deciding for itself how to manage
it's more like the government
sets very basic uh guard rails
essentially um to guide the actions by
the pro I believe so I think that that
would be one way to get at kind of what
your your issue is that's a that's
really does address what I me asking
about yes um I don't want to uh hog the
uh questions here but I don't see any
question
um and that concerns we have paint we
have mercury we have uh spent
Electronics we have uh postc consumer
packaging a whole list of products that
are good candidates to uh incorporate
and into a extended producer
responsibility create the grave
legislation um if you had a PR for every
one of those uh areas does that make it
un again speculation because again we're
doing things that are maybe a little bit
on Cutting Edge does that make it um
more difficult for a state agency to
manage and would it be a simpler uh more
Draconian solution perhaps us to have
the state agency take on all of these
aspects rather than dealing with number
of individual um
PR and again I mean I know that we're
you know I don't expect it to a yes or
no
answer yeah I I guess there's like I
said before there's multiple ways to
approach it um I think
commonly epr has been targeted by
specific category or type of
product uh because then it's it's more
it's probably logistically easier to to
develop a program that's
targeted uh because if you're going to
have industry paying for it you want to
Target the industry that is responsible
uh so having one pro that I guess if
that's your question like one pro that
kind of oversees multiple different uh
epr programs versus PR for each
individual I would think having PR for
each individual e epr program would
probably be more logistically feasible
although it sounds like it might be you
know more Cooks in the kitchen so to
speak but I think it's be it's
just probably again I'm not I'm not an
expert on this but I think it's probably
more appropriate to have a pro that
is targeted to the industry that is
responsible for the given product that
the epr is covering I don't I know if
that answers your question but um it it
does to some degree and again I know
we're in an area that I mean I think
really I wasn't even think in terms of
PR but that's the state oh coming in and
mandating the entire process
um uh requiring information from
manufacturers
but having the state actually run the
entire epr program right uh as opposed
to you know and again you would get rid
of a lot of books in the kitchen that
way as we say I like that analogy um but
at the end of the day I I don't know if
it we really would be beneficial
to just try to apply one standard right
across the industry for the sake of
efficiency maybe we do need you know uh
individual watchdogs on these very
specific areas I really don't know um so
yes you did answer the uh question I
think to the best of our ability to
understand this time um I did have one
more
question go ahead now would Dees
presumably be the one uh to provide
these rules these guidelines to the
pr I believe so again it depends on what
legislation is actually produced and or
proposed um but I think commonly the
environmental agency in a given state
would be the one that is assigned kind
of responsibility for for Ru making
Administration enforcement and general
General
oversight and of course that does
require Staffing so anything we're
talking about with the uh I mean we
mentioned earlier I I think that that's
an important aspect that you know if we
are charging fees from industry in order
to manage this program some of those
fees will by necessity need to go to
Staffing at the dees I would imagine I
believe that there are programs that are
set up that way or at least reimburse
the the state um so that they have some
coverage for their
yes I guess this is a a separate uh
topic but generally in the in the same
conversation of everything uh I know
Dees has uh new rules coming out
regarding
landfills uh and we'll we'll touch on
those in the later days in the in the
environmental agriculture committee but
do any of those rule changes um apply to
single use uh materials single use
packaging do you know of I am so I'm
just to preface my comment I'm I'm not
directly involved with the ru making uh
project for for uh landfills but I
believe that the rules that are being
considered are more pertain they pertain
more to the operation of a landfill
citing
uh design and operation of the of the
facility I don't believe that we already
currently have the authority
to make prohibitions on certain things
being disposed of in a landfill I think
the Authority for that would probably
legislation I think this is my final
question for you
um
would
you have an opinion on whether I mean we
have these specific areas that we are
targeting you know we could let's say
we're going to do epr for paint only or
for electronics only or for uh packaging
only um but if we
do look at any individual organization
to pay their Fairway does that mean that
we're letting a number of organizations
off the hooks that were so they can I
think I heard the term
freeload meaning that if we're going to
look at um single use plastic bottles
but we're not going to look at
recyclable paper or paper of any
nature that's sort
of administering the laws perhaps in a
way I if I'm sorry I don't want to
interrupt if you're still no no I I
guess what I'm really saying is would
you see something like uh epr
legislation be more effective if for
comprehensive across the board or if we
initiated it one step at a time with
problem Industries that's really my
bottom line question okay um I think the
root of your question is probably more
it pertains more to epr for packaging
because that's such
a it's such a broad umbrella topic
um epr traditionally has been targeted
to very specific categories or types of
products like like you mentioned Mercury
Mercury was actually one of the first
epr programs in New Hampshire um and New
Hampshire was a leader on that
uh there's since been other states that
have implemented Mercury bands or
takeback programs for thermostats and
things like that electronics are another
common kind of contained self you
know uh just just just easier to
identify kind of product category when
you get into packaging then you get into
those questions of equity I believe uh
because there's so many different types
of packaging
so and I seem to recall there was some
testimony at the last committee meeting
I don't recall if it was uh from the
American Beverage Association or whether
it was from um just zero or both of them
uh but I believe that they advocated for
if you're going to be considering an epr
for packaging program to make sure that
it is all-encompassing so that you're
not just
targeting plastic
containers uh and then leaving out paper
because paper of the recycling stream
paper is probably roughly 50 maybe even
more maybe 60% of the total recycling
Stream So if the goal of the epr program
is to limit the cost burden for
municipalities and the epr program only
covers a certain part of that stream so
to speak uh then you're kind of missing
the boat um you know especially if
you're leaving paper out so I think that
I believe that was a a comment that came
up in previous testimony that it's
important especially with packaging epr
to look at the entire uh kind of the the
whole pie of what is being
managed does that help with your
question it helps me a great deal thank
you so
much any further
questions I want to thank thank you for
showing up today and thank you hopefully
future I'm hoping that next we can
engage in a conversation about oh I I
I'll be I I'll be right up in front I'm
thinking that our main sticking point or
the main thing we we need to decide
to look to pursue extended producer
responsibility in the area I
mean are we looking at packaging at this
point single use packaging is part of
our
EPA I know that there are many uh other
areas we could be looking at we noted
some today electronics and the like and
I do think that they would
be I'd call them the lwh hanging float
fruit the easy things to address and I
think they should be addressed but I
think that also we should be addressing
single use packaging as well and I just
want to get a sense of how other people
that so uh when it comes to
epr
um first off I think a lot of companies
are already making their
packaging uh more environmentally
friendly friendly by using less material
uh lighter because that that's lowers
the cost right lowers the cost of
materials I use uh to make that
packaging uh companies who aren't doing
that well why aren't they doing that
well one they're doing it for possibly
durability uh durability when it comes
to uh handling when it comes to
transport uh when it comes to freshness
of the product when it comes to safety
to avoid any type of
contamination uh also for easy brand
recognition uh if companies are forced
to create a more environmentally uh
friendly uh container or packaging that
cost will ultimately fall to the
consumer whether you uh whether we have
these PR or
not uh I think
also let's say let's say epr legislation
does come about right and the consumer
goes shopping will they realize the
tradeoff that's been made when they see
an item that they used to buy it's more
of a a cost now and they say to
themselves well why is this cost so so
much higher well you know forget that
I'm going to go with the cheaper um um
cheaper product because it's it's it's
less and I I don't understand why this
product is so much more
now not to mention if if also if if
companies are forced to to again uh
Force into this
epr will that now create a burden a an
environmental impact uh as far as okay
what additional energy is needed what
additional resources are needed to
create this now environmental uh
friendly
packaging and just last but not least to
talk on this I know some states have
have implemented uh epr right now and I
don't think there is
enough um I I don't think enough time
has passed to get a good uh results to
get a sufficient amount of results to
justify uh epr
legislation that's all I have to say
thank you oh very good comments thank
you I think I'll like to continue with
other people look to weigh in but I
would like to ask one
question
and I
I don't have an answer on this I think
there's a lot of information out there
but I have read in some cases that epr
the cost of epr has not found its way to
the consumer in other places where it's
been done um but I think that's an
important point and I don't want to sit
here and you know make
that
a a point where that we're going to live
or die on unless we have the facts
established would you be open open to
investigating that as a
possibility to investigating uh what in
particular whether or not epr does add
costs I I think um that would involve
reaching out to manufacturers that would
involve reaching out to these producers
uh in these states to to see if
um what what additional cost has been
made if if any uh uh the price price
increase on their products if any has
been made um so I mean I can certainly
look into that I think we should I think
we could all sure sure but I I also
think that part of the charge of this
bill is reduce Municipal costs and that
would probably also imply consumer cost
so I think that if we can't do this I I
would agree it would be nonstarter if
that were indeed the case uh let's hear
from AR next and then thank
you I was uh I was reading of a study
done in Ontario and they use the blue
box system and they figure they're
getting about a little over 29% of their
Plastics back by doing that MH at a cost
of a little over 99 million a year that
that's the cost to run this program now
assuming every cost is constant if
if epr was was enforced through the
companies uh to get 100% recyclability
would raise that cost to about 471
million I I don't believe the consumers
would eat that cost I think it I mean
the producers I believe it would be
passed on to the consumers and and my
fear is the the people that get affected
the most of the lowincome people uh by
increasing the cost of the product so
that
it thank you Mr chair um so we're having
a
philosophical discussion about who Bears
first of all what we should do and who
Bears the costs um but um right now the
reason we're having this discussion is
that everybody all manners of our
economy are bearing the costs so doing
nothing we are bearing the costs
figuring out what we can do um is the
charge of of this committee and it is
actually the
responsibility of the manufacturers and
product um uh
Distributors to fold in
the environmental costs associated with
their product into the lifestyle of life
cycle of their product that's their
responsibility they have to figure it
out right now the cheapest way for them
to get their products to us is the way
we are getting it and it is costing us
it is costing all of us now in the
immediate point of purchase sale
a container of
um a container of milk and I'm thinking
of like the containers that have very
thick plastic and they have a very dark
coating to protect the milk inside and
the very heavy lid I'm not talking
necessarily about the very flimsy
crushable um half gallon containers
there's a lot of different for instance
and I'm this is just an example lots of
different types of containers for milk
looking at the pantheon of all of these
types of containers and you can buy milk
in um in boxes too and we used to buy
milk only in glass and the reason we
don't buy milk only in glass is it's
more expensive for the producer to buy
milk only in to sell us milk only in
glass so is glass the most efficient way
to deliver a particular product is it
the most efficient thing to uh recycle
do we have the capacity to recycle
that putting that responsibility back
onto the
manufacturer is what we are trying to
figure out and assuming that the
manufacturer will throw up their hands
and say oh we just can't do it and it's
going to cost you all particularly your
lowincome uh
consumers another
20% that is throwing a them problem back
on to us we already have the problem
we're looking for their help in fixing
the problem so I would I would just like
for us to take a more macro view of
where the responsibility lies and we
have um you know we have a series of
States Maine is already doing this
um so there's you know what we could
take their
um their bill that was
uh
1541 which specifically shifts the
responsibility and cost of manufacturing
of managing packaging waste from
municipalities and citizens to the
producers and it covers and right now
they're starting they're starting
they're not doing it you know know
everything what they're starting with is
plastic containers cardboard boxes and
other non-recyclables so they are just
starting here so while we may not have a
bread of of um history across the United
States to look at we do have some and so
um we were very I think was mentioned
very forth thinking and and proactive
about addressing in our Mercury issues
and so we we could do that I mean our
charge is to look at what other states
are doing and then figure out what would
be best for us but I would not hesitate
at all at all um by
the
assumption that a cost shift is
inevitable um in fact it can be brought
into you know figuring out how a uh
manufacturer pays for it and how much
that they can pass on to the consumer um
we we have we can have those discussions
um I just I I don't want to get caught I
I think personally I don't want to get
caught up in like I don't certainly
wouldn't want to tell parter and gamble
that they you know have to do more about
their tide jugs and um all the pack all
the plastic that goes on every bar of
soap that they produce and the
clamshells that go on on to all of their
razors because it's just going to cost
more and razors are already $15 like
nope there are other companies that
package those things in
in in uh cardboard they don't do the
clam shells that are impossible to get R
up and have to be uh recycled and not
taken at all of our recycling centers
like that's a Proctor and Gamble problem
they have created a problem from us for
us we need to bring it back to them and
say okay what you're sending us is not
okay this is not working
out we need in New Hampshire you can't
send us clam shells like that anymore we
could do that like you we could actually
do
that could I
also express my understanding of a EPA
bill it doesn't forbid them from sending
clam shells or plastic bottles to New
Hampshire but what it does do is that's
if you're going to package that way
you're going to be responsible for the
entire product cradle to grave and the
municipality will no longer have to pick
up on the price of disposing of these
items which should lower the taxes of
that municipality if they're not having
to have additional tipping fees in this
area I think that was the original
purpose of my buil not really to Outlaw
these but just to give Financial
incentives that choose other paths
that's how I see this epr being more
effective exactly like this this is the
discussion should you know is
it this end is like telling a a a
producer that like we're not going to
New Hampshire is not going to Bear the
responsibility of recycling Plastics
that's that would be a wild thing to do
but that could be at this end of the
spectrum versus bring it all in here we
don't care we're just going to fill up
our landfills um so we need to find
somewhere kind of close to here where we
are encouraging through our um
legislative rules regulations statutes
to minimize the amount of this kind of
product that comes into the state and
should you choose to continue to send
this kind of product it will it will
cost you a little bit more um
Oregon not afraid to do that they did a
massive massive overhaul on um their
plastic pollution um by charging higher
product fees
um for non-recyclable products to bring
them
in so New Jersey has um a very very
comprehensive law so there's we have
templates we can pick one picking Maine
or New Jersey very East Coast I mean the
other ones that are very that are a
little more ahead of us um because
they've only because they've been doing
it a little longer is Washington Oregon
California and Colorado um so if we if
we were looking for an East Coast
sensibility we have two we could take
those mark them
up put a couple versions to the
committee
and and send that off as a report I
don't know how you all feel about that
that that that would be the work of the
the larger committee to take a template
from us
and I I know that this is exact kind
dialogue I think we need right now and
thank you for engaging in it um I'm
going to go back to something I asked
earlier um if we had safeguards to
prevent these costs from going back to
Consumers and we could see what other
states have done to enact similar
safeguards would that relieve some of
our concern in this
area as far as you're
concerned so again I think I'm still a
kind of wait and see approach let enough
time go by in these states where they
have enacted it and I do agree that it's
I think it's a good idea to reach out to
some of these maybe
manufacturers my my old thing is that
there's no way that the producers are
just going to eat eat these costs out of
the kindness of their heart without
passing it on to the consumer and in a
time like this where we have high
inflation cost living is harder it's
it's
unreasonable to put this burden on the
consumer
um especially for some of these mom and
pop type uh businesses
where they can't compete they're are
already struggling to compete with the
larger organizations and forcing this on
them is
um it just it's you can't you can't ask
no please please but again uh the big I
think the big thing is uh you're right
we should be reaching out to some of
these manufacturers in in Oregon and
Massachusetts
Maine yeah um thank you thank you Mr
chair and thank you I I I really do
appreciate um the spot in which you are
um highlighting the pain point of this
entire production and
um I want
to also highlight that we are already
paying those
costs we all are
already paying for this so um and it is
and the insidiousness of it is that it
is hidden in a way that it is spread
across everybody but those Mom and Pops
um as well as the larger manufacturers
um and the larger Distributors and our
small businesses are already paying the
cost the mom and pops are paying more
because they actually live here their
businesses are here they're paying the
property
taxes here and they're paying the
Tipping fees here
unlike the Walmarts that are not a New
Hampshire based organization so the Mom
and Pops have to pay more now so I feel
like we're all we're the reason we're
even talking about this is because it's
costing us too much um and I I I want to
make sure that we're that we um have a
holistic view of like this is a this is
a problem that is expensive now so if we
don't do something now it's not going to
get any
cheaper it's just going to deflect who
it so so what you're saying is then by
enacting epr even though the
costs uh will be passed on the consumer
you're saying our taxes will be lowered
as as a
result
thank you for the question I am I did
not put up a a rubric of where the cost
shifting goes what I'm pointing out is
that there is a cost that we are bearing
right now there you there may be maybe a
direct line between a regulatory
fee um that addresses epr that may
result in a downshifting of that cost to
our local businesses and consumers but
that is not a given that's not a
straight line um and that is not a
formula that is reflected in the
programs that exist right now so I don't
think we have an either or um but what
we do know is that the
responsibility for changing the
trajectory we're on on it has to come
from the
manufacturers so if we're going to have
um you
know we're going to have hundreds of
thousands of bottles of Li of liquid
laundry detergent those bottles have to
go somewhere and there's no incentive to
package them any differently because the
company that you know Unilever keeps
sending them in and we keep buying them
and it's not unilever's problem once it
gets onto the store shelves once they've
brought it to a store like they're out
but now New Hampshire is deluged with
unil Unilever bottles left right and
center and now we have to figure out
what to do with them and here we have
some organizations that are like oh you
know what we should do we should totally
burn all of them and make um a and do um
chemical recycling which we know
chemical recycling blows out an enormous
enormous amount of pollution into the
environment because we already talked
about this last session in um s in the
energy committee and the Senate so that
chemical recycling is such a
new way of doing things um that you know
we should not be looking to invite more
pollution into the state by because
we're we're afraid to tell Proctor and
Gamble or Unilever that we would like
less
plastic so we can cut down and have they
they need they are not incentivized to
repackage anything right now because
it's working for them they're making a
ton of money there's no incentives to do
anything different and yes you are
absolutely correct correction not going
to do it out of the goodness of their
hearts you know they're not going to
greenwash this just for funsies so we're
going to have to come up with a okay
here's how we're going to do it in New
Hampshire I see what you're doing in
Maine I see what's happening in Colorado
we're going to take this tact it's not
an all or nothing it's a start so
um you know right now how much you know
we're paying
millions in waste disposal Millions
that thank you yes I would like to just
suggest this is my suggestion only that
such things as advanced recycling is
part of the further end of what we need
to address here and I'm my own personal
concern would be uh stopping the waste
flow that's coming into the state rather
than talk about you know how where we're
going to put the next landfill or how
we're going to do with Advanced
recycling I think these are all
extremely valid
concerns but I'd like to try to limit
oursel to the concerns around uh
extended producer responsibility to
lower the waste flow and again to go
back to what the bill says and a lower
Municipal costs um but I do appreciate
your comments very
much but we get we got to hear from
Arnie too but go ahead no please please
yeah so um also want to just I want to
just put it out there so that it's um
it's on our discussion Horizon that um
businesses like Amazon and Unilever I'm
sorry to be beating up on them
specifically it just happens to come to
Ry right now Proctor and Gamble um they
already are in
compliance with um regulations that are
are far far more complicated and
restrictive in
Europe and everybody there seems to be
able to access shaving razors and
batteries and paint and laundry
detergent and we are letting them run
rough shod because we're afraid that oh
well our laundry detergent might but go
up by 50 Cents well it seems like in
Europe they're able to wash their
clothes and um and not be gouged for it
and this is you know I'm I'm
not I'm not unafraid to say that I see a
pattern in American manufacturing and
charging Americans for products that go
into other spaces of the world where
those other places in the world enjoy a
far lower cost than than we
do um and and we're the ones who have to
recycle all this stuff you know we have
a little bit more space than they do in
Europe but they have they have already
jumped ahead they're way ahead of us in
putting restrictions on that
um packaging before it even gets to
their
consumers so it's not it's not that it's
not been done before it's just that it's
here
I I guess I'd like to see more about uh
how how it's working out in Maine in New
Jersey maybe Colorado I'd like to see
more data on that um as as far as
packaging there are things I think that
that wouldn't uh affect the cost maybe
like egg cartons instead of being in in
plastic com in cardboard you know if we
could mandate things like that I I uh I
I think I might be naive because where I
live in Coos County Recycling is a big
deal up there and we the re I go buy the
recycling center on my way to work and I
go buy it on my way home and it's it's
very effective I I
uh at our last meeting I I talked to a
few people and
apparently in some parts of the state
it's not that big of a deal and they
just throw the recycling in with the
garbage and I
I was very naive to to that uh but
I I just hate to see the I think there's
things that can be improved but I don't
think it should be a total uh
responsibility of of the manufacturers I
I don't see how that's going to work
up I'd like to this again I think I was
another one of those people that was
very naive and it was an eye opening
experience to hear about how much was
not being recycling in our more urban
settings my compost goes to a compost
pile doesn't everybody do that um but
when it comes to things like egg cartons
we're not outlawing plastic egg cartons
where they saying if you want to package
your eggs in that way I think an EPA law
effectively would I think this is the
gist of an ep the way I understand it
would be choose paper or plastic if you
choose paper it will be a lower
um cost lower fee to you in order for us
to have our transfer
stations uh dispose of that than if you
choose another item and I I know if
that's really true that those two
particular products I suspect it is but
it's not mandating them to package in a
certain way it's giving them incentives
to choose whatever is uh best for them
and I kind of think that's maybe key the
other thing which I'm kind of feeling
about and this is why I'm concerned
about a wait and see attitude is New
Hampshire is already getting a lot of
our
um waste flow right now from our
neighboring states and Maine has already
enacted EPA law
epr Vermont is in the process of it
Massachusetts in the process of it New
York is well along and Canada our
neighbors to North also have
EP and I would hate to be the last
player in the game to do it when we know
that our current landfills are already
bursting at the seams because of outof
State transferring I know not all
landfills do it some are admirable for
not doing that but a lot of landfills do
and I don't know how much more pork
State can take so I I'd rather be
proactive
personally um so please go ahead uh
so I'm on the environment and
agriculture committee and we heard a lot
of testimony uh I think more proactive
things are like the composting bill that
was brought up um and and I really
respect the Senate's opinion I uh about
uh burning trash to energy but like
wheelator that's old technology they
have
plasma uh facilities that they're very
expensive but they're very clean I I I
don't know why we don't look more into
that there it's not like the old Wheel
librator Systems they have scrubbers
they have the the big problem there is
the expense of the facility but I think
once it's in place I think that uh
landfill permitting that's been a a big
issue for a long time
here you know maybe we need to look into
other
avenues yes and Wheeler is right now my
district
um the charge of this committee though
is to find out how
to what we do before it even has to go
to a place like wheeler breider
like we are looking to be proactive so
that we are not cleaning up um you know
if we had if you had a bunch of toddlers
running around your house with chocolate
snack
packs the easy way to solve that problem
isn't to buy more Lysol wipes to wipe
down your house because the toddlers are
running around with chocolate snackpack
fingers you bring down you take the
snack packs away and figure out a way to
seit them at a table with napkins and
spoons to do it differently right so we
want to prevent the mess before we spend
a lot of money and time cleaning up the
mess and one of the ways to prevent the
mess is to provide incentives for
manufacturers um
to put better product packaging into the
state of New Hampshire it's not telling
them like if you want to package in clam
shells that's what you want to do that's
how you want to approach your business
go for it but clam shells are going to
cost you more to put into the state of
New Hampshire than an a recycling
biodegradable box because those exist in
the world and we buy products in them
right now so it would be what we're
looking for is an incentive program a
way to
incentivize producers to put better
product packaging into the state of New
Hampshire and if they refuse to then
they need to pay for that they need to
either pay when it comes in or they need
to participate in paying to to get rid
of it but what we're trying to do is
incentivize better packaging and when
you do that
um you will we will we will get a better
product line we will get more recyclable
things there are fewer and and this is
not just about personal um products you
know we're our a lot of the waste comes
from places that buy an enormous amount
of stuff like universities and Hospital
hospitals and schools um and our and our
businesses that are also bringing in a
lot of products to serve their workers
um so they're generating a lot of waste
too it's not just me and you in our in
our little houses um and all of that got
to go to a
municipal place to be disposed of and it
costs money for those businesses to get
rid of that trash
so it's the incentivizing to do
better
so thank you Mr chairman uh so when you
say
incentivize well could it be that the
business the businesses the companies
who opt into this uh program could there
incentives that may be something where
the business can say all
right based on these tax
incentives we could afford to make our
containers more environmentally friendly
make it more eco-friendly without having
to uh tack on that additional uh price
consumer thank you thank you for the
question
um we're not taxing them to bring
products in the state to begin with
that's not we would have to create a tax
structure for that and I'm not
advocating creating a tax structure um
what I what I
I should
clarify um I think
that using a model like
Maine which would create a
sustainability fund so if you put better
products into main excellent um if you
insist on continuing to use the product
packaging that is problematic for us to
dis ose of then we may have to charge
you a fee because we've got to dispose
of that stuff that you are bringing into
the state so your incentive is to design
better packaging which is not a
reinvention of the wheel because there
are different packaging available for
most of these products in different
places around the world they are not
going to be throwing up their hands like
oh my God what are we going to do we're
never going to be able to sell in New
Hampshire that's that is absolutely not
true because it's happening in Maine
it's happening in Canada it's happening
in Europe there are different your
products show up in different forms same
product comes in different packaging in
different parts of the world um but if
there's an incentive to bring better
packaging that is better to easier to
get rid of doesn't take up all that
space if they choose not to that's a
business decision on them which no we
want to bring in all of our two gallon
containers of laundry detergent with the
thick plastic that is you know takes a
great deal of time to
recycle um great that's what you want to
do we're going to need you to contribute
into the sustainability fund because it
costs us to get rid of that stuff so
at
thanks for taking my question sure
forgive my ignorance in this matter but
how do how do we monitor what they're
using for packaging and at what cost
does this come like like do we have to I
works I just don't want to put you on
the spot repeatedly uh I but uh I that's
what my naive self thought that well epr
it works in Europe it works in states
where we've enacted it um it's an
incentive for business it's not a tax
it's to reduce consumer costs to me it
seems like you know I'll be frank you
know I I hear your concerns but I'm a
bit naive and I'm thinking that it seems
like pretty obvious to me that this is a
good thing to move forward forward with
I think we need to really address your
concerns fully and then if we can't come
to agreement then we should proceed with
a different report than what I was
hoping for however to get to your
question we know what they're sending
into our state uh we have records of
that and we could charge the Department
of Environmental Services with
monitoring this or
a or a producer responsibility or
organization do I have that right a PR
yeah um a private one to take these
numbers and say okay this is what you're
sending in it contains this much uh
material that could be dealt with
differently this is good we're going to
prate the disposal you on these we're
going to charge you a fee in order to
dispose of these and that fee will be
returned down to the municipal level
after administrative costs are taken out
of it um it's basically goes back to
this going back to
saying we're giving you a choice on this
but we know what they're bringing into
the state and we have organizations that
will track what they bring into the
state from there it's a simple matter of
you know pretty obvious guess is that it
ends up in our landfill once it comes in
but I was not I I thought we'd actually
have people out in the landfills
originally counting bottles and so I
mean it that is a good question
please so these administrative fees how
do how do we know they're not more
than uh than what we're paying right now
for the recycling and in the trash fees
well I would expect that if we are
legislating and saying on top of what
our uh Oran our agencies are paying then
we would know if they are greater uh um
I should also add I don't think this is
something that we're going to pass one
law and everything's going to be perfect
from here on out I think there's a
number of steps in even doing what we
call Echo modulation finding out that
sweet spot
where um if you want to dispose of this
this is how much it really
costs how can we provide in financial
incentive for to change and then
addressing a stewardship fee on those
changes um it's it's it's a process
which is why I also feel a certain
urgency for moving forward with this
because it is not something that's going
to happen overnight it is a process I
did I yeah okay I hope I addressed maybe
not to your satisfaction but at least
yeah uh thank you Mr chairman um and
when you say epr Works in other states I
don't think we know if it works for all
parties in other states it's prob it's
working right now the process is working
they they've implemented it but is it
working best for all parties again I
think that remains to be seen and I know
we're supposed to be focused on
epr uh but to accomplish the goals for
which we want to accomplish I think
there are other methods new
technologies looking at different
Avenues uh for which the waste comes
into the straight into the state in
order to say all right let's find a way
around the US Commerce Clause to say
okay well Mass this waste has this trash
has to go to waste energy or you you're
not going to get a tariff uh on on any
waste you want to bring into the state
there are other ways around uh looking
at uh epr to accomplish these goals
only
is
um I don't know if this is the best
to is that an I don't know or is this
mean you don't believe that it is I'm
asking frankly because I I have another
follow-up
question I don't yet believe that it is
because we
haven't we haven't let enough time
elapse in these other states to fully
see the uh results
and and to say okay it is working it is
sufficient it works best for all parties
and again I think it's I think I'm still
approach okay I
would think that we like being first in
the
nation um I think when we have a waste
flow
that's in Far excess of what our
neighbors are facing I don't know if we
have the luxury of doing a wait and see
and let's figure out what other states
do I I I I would hate to be the last one
on board of this one personally now
that's my feeling and we're going to you
know we can choose to this be on that
but I guess my deeper question would be
um right now for the purpose of moving
forward I'm getting this sense that
we're tell tell me I'm wrong I mean
sense we're pretty much split on what
we'd like to see happen
but what I would like to ask is
there a couple of concerns that we can
look at that would
alleviate our disposition towards moving
ahead what would the if I were ask you
what maybe your one or two or even three
chief concerns are in enacting EPA
legislation maybe we could focus on them
and see if we can move past them I'm
sorry
oh did I say it
again I'm so
sorry I am horrible with anagrams um
does that sound reasonable though moving
ahead that way try to find out what our
stopping points are what are the areas
we think may need further study before
we come with an answer please go
ahead
so Epi our our end game is to keep
things out of the landfill is that I
mean that's lower the cost okay lower
the cost for yeah
um I I I do believe there there may be
some some things that can be done but I
I don't think
that's I think there's other things that
are much more important uh that like the
land the composting bill that would keep
25% out of the landfills per year that's
huge I think that's a step in the right
direction right uh
I don't want to say
mandating uh recycling but maybe make
education about it more important or or
some way find you know if we could get
more people to
recycle
uh I I don't I I agree that wheelator is
old technology but there are ways uh
what I've been reading is is these
plasma I'm not sure the the full name of
it the
plasma systems that that incinerate
trash into energy with very little um
they have scrubbers they have all the
it's the the downside there is it's
expensive but they claim that's cleaner
than than our universities or our
hospitals but they what they're putting
out I I think that those are the types
of things we I mean this this seems like
a small part uh piece of the pie is uh
the E epr to me is I I I think there's
room for things that could be done like
you said on a Case by casee
basis I I just think that's where we're
looking in the wrong place for what what
achieve Mr thank you Mr chair um thank
you I think that you're right this is
multifaceted and we have um
opportunities to look on that back end
of how our we how are we then further
recycling shipping out burying burning
whatever that is composting that is on
that end of the spectrum absolutely
needs some some more definitive
direction right yeah definitive
Direction um for the purposes of this
particular committee though we're very
limited in our scope um in fact we
absolutely like have to our statutory
obligation is to study extended producer
responsibility as a mechanism for
meeting the waste reduction goals
established in RSA 149 M and reduce the
tax burden that Solid Waste Disposal
places on
municipalities we are supposed to
examine existing e ER epr laws in other
States territories and International jur
jurisdictions and establish priorities
for more in-depth study possible targets
for epr include packaging single-use
Plastics beverage containers electronic
waste batteries automotive waste and
hazardous waste we are to assess how
those laws that exist in other places
can be adapted to our existing Solid
Waste Recovery
infrastructure and what support
the Department of Environmental Services
would
require for us to implement those laws
so there are three other things and we
have met the
obligations um by soliciting stakeholder
input the chair has solicited
stakeholder input to talk to us here um
on what their approaches are um we uh we
are to suggest possible legislation or
rules
based on what we have found in other
states countries municipalities for the
purpose of reducing our Municipal tax
burdens that is all we are charged here
to do it is a big big big concept and
Industry to wrap your head around but it
is not our charge to eat the whole
elephant we just have to eat a teeny
part of it and we have to tell people
how we did that that so um we have the
things that we have not done as of right
now is fully engage in what other states
there are six other states who have
definitive policy in statute there are
14 other states 11 I think um it's in
the low teen mid- teens who are doing
exactly what we're doing figuring out
what they're going to do because they're
also buried in trash
so what we have to do is now look at
what the EU is doing and the other
states so we have another meeting I
don't think we have to do that right now
I'm happy to send out some of my
research to the committee so everybody's
on the same page if you would like to
read that um but our charge um line
14 of of this bill is to examine epr
laws in other States territories and
international jurisdictions and to
establish priorities for more in depth
study so by November we have to have
done all of these things and Report out
that we
studied you know this state this state
this state this country here's what
they're doing here's where we think New
Hampshire might be able to jump in on
this new way of approaching municipal
waste so we have multiple conversations
going on across multiple committees
about what's happening with w
after it's already here this this
subcommittee is supposed to be just
looking at what do we do before it even
gets here that's that's all we have to
do but we all have some really great
ideas about taking legislation about the
other end further which is great but we
we really do have a very narrow Lane
that we have to stay in um so I would I
would hope that we can maybe have a
draft report in the next committee so
that we can sign
off if that's reasonable but we we
really really do have to stay in our
lane cuz that's what we are statutorily
bound to
do thank you Mr
chair um thank you Senator
uh in in line with what the senator is
saying this is what we're supposed to
look at nothing else and then my
personal opinion is a much longer
studying time frame will be need to is
done given the fact we only have until
November November 1st that that's not
enough time I don't believe that's
enough time to say hey we've researched
it and we we said yeah it's great it
should be it should be for New
Hampshire I think at least a year in my
opinion at least a year
to uh talk with these manufacturers in
in Maine Oregon elsewhere to see how
it's affected their
economies much more time is needed um
uh I'd like
to thank you for all your comments I
think with
help if we could we have a record of
them uh beauty of streaming is that we
can all go back and watch and I plan on
taking a lot of wisdom away from this
meeting this morning at the same time it
would also help if there's anything that
I would care to put in writing
um I am taking it on myself is chair to
spearhead the drafting of a report
um I don't think anybody else is
chopping in the bit to do that but if
you are please please let me
okay okay well well but but but it would
be a great assistance if you would if
you would rather than have your records
taken offline if you wanted to submit
them in a written form you know perhaps
you might want to put more succinctly
that's what I'm saying so please please
write
um Mr Sher if I may that's the nature of
these
um of these committees is that it is a
short amount of time which is why
they're so narrowly scoped um and why
approaching it with with a very clear
expectation that we are looking at EV
every every study committee is tackling
an
enormous um issue and the way that we
break break down these enormous issues
is to put smaller pieces of them in the
study committee so there are other study
committees doing other things and this
happens like year round year round year
round we are not supposed to
solve the issue but we are supposed to
as every study committee is um charged
with putting our our academic and best
foot forward our research best foot
forward and our um
responsibility as legislators to follow
the statute and participate in bringing
the state just that much further along
so it would be great to have a year but
we don't we were given 45 days so we got
to do the best we can with 45 days
following the structure of what we have
been given by the legislature um and you
know it's not impossible it's just it
sometimes it doesn't feel good to do all
of the things cuz we all like now that
you get your fingers in it you start to
understand the issues you want to do
more you want to go deeper but this is
this is the beginning for which we all
can jump off and do more because you've
got the background to bring more people
in so it can be overwhelming to try to
narrow it down um but it's not
impossible it's a very specific narrow
scope and you know a recommendation may
be to create a long
longterm
um research study that is in
collaboration with Dees you know that
recommendation thank you yeah thank
you so this is the first study committee
I'm on so I I'm not exactly sure how
this works one once
we make a report for this then then what
happens well we make the report uh
it's this is my second study committee
but perhaps you have other people in the
room who can speak otherwise uh this
committee the report will be on file for
those that care to see it we have the
option of presenting legislation based
on this report as well um the OS will
draft legislation according to our
guidelines if we choose to do as much
um my read of the uh and of course you
were all there
too uh of of the um Ena committee when
this uh when this was study committee
was
established was that a small group of
people would
be more quick in coming up with
potential legislation with addressing it
than a large study commission that that
I originally proposed I I proposed a
study commission I don't if you recall
that or not that would have lasted well
over a year and looked at the problem
that way and I think the general feeling
Comm of the ENA was they want to see
something more strategic and something
happening more
quickly hence my urgency along with my
urgency knowing that if we could reduce
waste 5% 2% it's a reduction in the
goals were set 1995 that we have not
even come close to achieving every year
it's ground anything we could do at this
point and I think it's perhaps and com
upon every committee that's meeting to
have progress in this area to do all
they can so I would strongly urge that
if we can come to consensus on some type
of legislation it would give us the
ability to get our hands dirty in the
matter and to see what may or may not
work according to Future legislation so
that's my may I take that as the F my
final word
and do we have can we bring this to a
yes